لواء عبري اخر ينسحب من القطاع والولايات
المتحده تستخدم الفيتو مجددا ضد القطاع
وروسيا ترد فيما مجلس الامن الحربي العبري
يعقد اجتماعا جديدا مصر تقدم اقتراحا
لتلبي بشان التهدئه والحكومه العبريه تقدم
مقترحا للفصائل اكثر من 20 دوله تجتمع في
البحر الاحمر وواشنطن تتوعد الصين وبيكن
تستمر بمطالبها امام الامريكان الجيش
الامريكي يصرح في هذه الحاله سيتعين علينا
القتال بدلا من الاوكرانيين الدول الغربيه
تستعد لحرب بارده جديده وموسكو لمن سيحاول
المساسه باصول روسيا المجمده لن نترككم
وشان الرعب الروسي ينتشر بغواصه نوويه
جديده واشنطن تفشل
السلام القمم تعقد المجالس تجتمع الدول
تتحرك الشعوب تحتاج تعترض تتظاهر لاجل ما
يجري في القطاع وبعد ان فشلت الو الولايات
المتحده باستخدامها حق النقض الفيتو
تعديلا يدعو لوقف اطلاق النار في القطاع
اقترحته روسيا على قرار مجلس الامن الدولي
الداعي لتوسيع تسليم المساعدات في القطاع
ليخرج المندوب الروسي لدى المجلس فاسيلي ن
بينزي ويصرح ان مجلس الامن شهد تصرفا غير
مسؤول وقاسيا من واشنطن التي لجئ لادوات
تخريبيه مختلفه لمنع اصدار قرار بشان
القطاع مضيفا اما ان يعتمد المجلس قرارا
يرضي واشنطن او لا تعتمد اي من القرارات
التي تخرج فيما تبنى مجلس الامن الدولي
قرارا يطالب تلبيب والفصائل بتسهيل ايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه الى جميع انحاء
القطاع ويدعو ايضا الامين العام للامم
المتحده لتعيين منسق لتسليم هذه المساعدات
هذا وافادت وسائل اعلام عبريه بان مجلس
الحرب كان قد اجتمع في تل ابيب وسطه
اختلافات حول اطر التفاوض من اجل صفقه
تبادل جديده من جهه ثانيه اكد رئيس
الوزراء العبر نتنياهو ان تلبيب لن توقف
الحرب وستقل حتى النصر وتصفيه الفصائل
واستعاده المخطوفين على حد تعبيره وقال في
كلمات نشرها على حسابه على موقع اكس انه
سيتم العمل على ان لا يشكل القطاع اي
تهديد لتل ابيب بعد الحرب واليكم المصدر
افادت وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه بان مجلس
الحرب يجتمع في تلبيب وسط خلافات حول اطر
التفاوض من اجل صفقه تبادله جديده ب جهه
ثانيه اكد رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنمي
نتنياهو ان اسرائيل لن توقف الحرب وستقل
حتى النصر وتصفيه حماس واستعاده المخطوفين
بالمقابل قال موقع انترسبت الامريكي ان
تلبيب تنجح في القضاء على المدنيين وتدمير
بناهم التحتيه في القطاع لكن زحفها البري
ضد الفصائل يتحول الى مستنقع واضافت ان
بايدن ونتنياهو يدركان ما لا يجران على
قوله علنا وهو ان الامور على المستوى
العسكري لا تسير على ما يرى وان تلبيب
النوويه التي تمتلك اسلحه حديثه وتحظى
بدعم كامل من اقوى دوله في العالم تسعى
بشده لتحقيق نصر تكتيكي على الفصائل وها
هو المصدر يتحدث في
الانترسكس على ما يرام وان اسرائيل الدوله
النوويه التي تمتلك اسلحه حديثه وتحظى
بدعم كامل من اقوى دوله في العالم تسعى
بشده لتحقيق نصر تكتيكي على حماس هنا قالت
صحيفه يديعوت احر نوت العبر ان مسؤولين
امنيين مصريين اقترحوا على تلبيب والفصائل
صفقه جديده لتبادل الاسر واعلان هدنه
انسانيه في القطاع بينما تريد تل ابيب
رؤيه مطالب الفصائل فيما يتعلق باسماء
الاسرى الذين تريد الفصائل اطلاق سراحهم
كجزء من الصفقه قبل الموافقه على هذه
الخطوه حتى ان شبكه سي ان ان ذكرت ان
الحكومه العبريه قدمت عرضا جديدا للفصائل
يتضمن وقف القتال في القطاع لمده اسبوع
مقابل اطلاق راح 35 رهينا و في الميدان
اعلنت القناه 12 العبريه ان جنود الكتبه
13 من لواء جولاني في الجيش العبري انسحبت
من القطاع ليلتقطوا انفاسهم وينظم صفوفهم
بعد تكبدهم خسائر فادحه لنات بالمصدر نبدا
بما تحدثت عنه وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه عن
سحب كتيبه او لواء جولاني من قطاع غزه
والقناه الثال ع تحدثت عن ضروره ربما
تنظيم صفوف هذه الكتيبه فيما اعلنت
المقاومه العراقيه انها تمكنت من ضرب حقل
كاريش للغاز في البحر المتوسط وصفان الحقل
بانه هدف حيوي وذلك ردا على الجرائم في
القطاع من جهه اخرى كشف تحليل لشبكه سي ان
ان ان تل ابيب اسقطت مئات القنابل التي
يصل وزن الواحده منها الى ال000 رطل على
القطاع واستند تحليل سي ان ان الى ان صور
الاقمار الاصطناعيه التي تظهر اكثر من 500
حفره ارتطام يزيد قطر كل واحده عن ا 12
مترا في التطورات وعلى الحدود اللبنانيه
افادت قناه الجزيره باطلاق اكثر من 20
صاروخا من جنوب لبنان باتجاه مواقع عسكريه
عبريه بين مستوطنتي زرعيت وشوه في البحر
الاحمر قالت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ان
اكثر من 20 دوله وافقت حتى الان على
المشاركه في التحالف المعروف باسم عمليه
حارس الازدهار في البحر الاحمر بينما لم
تؤكد بعض الدول مشاركتها الى الان في
التحالف فيما قالت دول اخرى ان جهودها
ستاتي في اطار اتفاقات بح قائمه بدلا من
عمليه جديده تقودها واشنطن وبعيدا عن
اجواء المعارك علق السيناتور الجمهوري
الامريكي لينسي جراهام على مقال نشرته
شبكه ان بي سي نيوز جاء فيه ان الرئيس
الصيني تشي جين بينغ ابلغ الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن خلال قمه اوبك في نوفمبر بان
الصين ملتزمه باعاده التوحيد السلمي مع
تايوان وقال جراهام متوعدا الصين بوضع
مسوده عقوبه جهنميه ضد بيكين في حال اقدمت
على محاوله استعاده السيطره على تايوان
هناك جددت الخارجيه الصينيه مطالبتها
واشنطن بضروره وقف تسليح تايوان ودعم
اعاده التوحيد السلمي للجزيره مع البر
الرئيسي
للصين استراتيجيه
جديده بعد قرابه عامين من الحرب في
اوكرانيا الغرب يغير استراتيجيته هنا قالت
صحيفه بوليتيكو ان الدول الغربيه تستعد
لحرب بارده جديده مع روسيا ونقلت عن وزير
الدفاع الفنلندي انتي كانين اشارته الى
قدره روسيا على انتاج السلاح ومواصله
الحرب لسنوات فيما قال الكولونيل بالجيش
الامريكي يوجين فيندمان لقناه ام اس ان بي
سي ان النيتو سيضطر لمحاربه روسيا الاكثر
قوه بعد الهزيمه النهائيه لاوكرانيا مضيفا
في هذه الحاله سيتعين علينا القتال بدلا
من الاوكرانيين من جانب اخر صرح رئيس
الوزراء الهنغاري فيكتور اوربان ان الصراع
في اوكرانيا هو عمليه عسكريه خاصه لان
روسيا لم تعلن الحرب على اوكرانيا تبدا
التعبئه العامه مضيفا انه لا ينبغي ان
تكون هناك حدود مشتركه بين هنغاريا وروسيا
في روسيا بعد ان اكد الكريملن ان
الاستيلاء على الاصول الروسيه المجمده بند
دائم مطروح على جدول اعمال الاتحاد
الاوروبي وواشنطن ويشكل خطرا يحدق بالنظام
المالي العالمي ليحذر المتحدث باسم
الرئاسه الروسيه ديميتري بيسكوف ان اولئك
الذين يحاولون المساس باصول روسيا المجمده
لمساعده اوكرانيا يجب ان يفهموا ان روسيا
لن تتركهم وشانهم في سياق اخر كان الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن قد وقع مرسوما يهدف الى
تجديد العقوبه على روسيا وحسب ما اعلن
المكتب الصحفي للبيت الابيض فالمر السوم
يهدف الى منع استخدام روسيا للانظمه
الماليه الدوليه لاستيراد المنتجات ذات
الاستخدام العسكري وغيرها من المنتجات
المهمه من دول ثالثه في الميدان الاوكراني
اعلنت الدفاع الروسيه انه تم اعتراض صاروخ
تكتيكي من طراز اتاكم از وث قاذفه صواريخ
متعدده من طرازه مارس
واوانا وثلا قنابل جويه موجهه من طراز
جدام بالاضافه الى
259 طائره دون طيار خلال اسبوع مع تكبيد
الجيش الاوكراني اكثر من
4690 قتيلا وجريحا وها نحن نتصفح المصدر
[موسيقى]
امامكم هذا وافادت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
باستيلاء روسيا على زمام المبادره في جميع
نقاط الاشتباك في الصراع مع كياف واوضحت
الصحيفه انه خلال الاسابيع القليله
الماضيه تمكنت روسيا من الاستيلاء على
مناطقه جديده وخلال ذلك تستمر روسيا
بتطوير غواصاتها النوويه حيث قال مدير
مصنع سيف ماش الروسي لبناء السفن
والغواصات ميخائيل بودين تينكو ان العمل
جار في المصنع على تطوير غواصه الامير
بوغار السكي النوويه والامير بوغار السكي
هي الغواصه الخامسه من فئه بوراي اي التي
تطورها روسيا في اطار المروع الحكومي اي
955 وتنتمي غواصات بوراي اي الى فئه الجيل
الرابع من الغواصات النوويه ويمكن لكل
غواصه حمل 16 صاروخا بولافا عابر للقارات
يعمل بالوقود الصلب فضلا عن انها مجهزه
بانظمه لاطلاق الربيدات من عيار
533 مليمترا بحسب موقع
ارتي